The Joe Rogan experience with you anymore.
Someone that you deeply loved and cared about.
You want them to suffer.
It's weird.
I mean,
it's normal.
So I guess it's not that weird,
but that the evil,
vicious jealousy,
you know,
like you see that vicious jealousy and chimpanzees,
like one of the things that chimpanzees do when the attack people,
one of the things they attack people over is unfairness.
Like a,
there was a terrible story about a guy who had kept a pet chimp and then brought
the chimp a birthday cake on his birthday.
Brian Posehn as a whole bit about it does it does you really?
Yeah.
Um,
and the other chimps found out that this chimps getting the birthday cake and I
saw it and they weren't getting any cake and they were fucking furious.
So someone had inadvertently left one of the gates open.
So the chimps got out,
tour this guy apart because of a birthday cake.
But it's that thing.
It's not like it was affecting them.
I was like,
he was doing something bad to them.
So they got out and killed him.
No,
they ripped his dick off because they didn't like the fact that give the other
champ a birthday cake.
Took his dick,
took his fingers,
took his feet.
But yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Plus it's so funny.
He's like,
the worst thing about that story for that guy is that everyone's gonna want to
hear it forever because it starts with,
so it was bringing a birthday cake to a chimpanzee and then you got to hear the
rest.
But that,
that anger and jealousy,
like there's evolution doesn't an evolutionary basis for,
oh,
is that what he looks like now?
Yeah.
Oh my God.
I'm going to show.
It's tough.
His fingers are missing his face,
his Muslim,
he's got one eye.
His nose is gone.
Oh,
look at that.
Frown on her face was ripped apart.
The pro stitched it together that way.
Awful.
Yeah.
It's fucking awful,
man.
Yeah.
You can't own a chimp crazy assholes.
They're the most vicious of all the primates next to people.
Aren't they good for like you can put like train them for like the first like
five years of their life and then they forget everything.
They just decided they're gonna fuck you up.
Yeah.
And they're so strong.
What does that one doing?
Is that the chimp?
No,
no,
but it just popped up in the same group of pictures,
shoes,
hairless champion.
There's some mean such a,
it's such a mean species.
You know,
there's a problem with Columbus monkeys in parts of Africa where chimps live
because they've eaten so many columns.
Monkeys that there the populations down 97%.
Yeah.
They rip them apart and eat them a lot while they're alive.
Either tiny colobus monkeys.
It's not big,
big enough to eat.
But uh,
is it David Attenborough documentary from the 90s where they first discovered
that chimps eat monkeys?
They really didn't know.
They thought the chimps were basically herbivores and then they got this video
footage of them hunting these monkeys and the way they would corral them and
beat them through the trees and then catch them.
And this monkey screaming while this chimp is ripping and apart from the hips
and just chewing it up,
pulling it apart from the,
and he's like,
and he's like basically ripping his legs in his ass,
end off and just eating it alive.
God,
Sam,
they're fucking mean man.
They're fucking mean to mean animal.
But w w what the,
I get the fact that,
look,
everything's mean in the jungle.
There's big cats and poisonous snakes and spiders and it's just a hard,
hard,
hard world.
But the thing that drives that gets me is the jealousy because I don't think
other animals experience jealousy the way chimps do this is that it right there.
Uh,
from the Attenborough,
they,
them,
they actually caught it.
Yeah.
So that's a monkey in his hand.
Jesus.
Yeah,
Dude.
The videos of it killing it while they're pulling it apart.
Like,
Whoa,
but the,
that jealousy that I want you to suffer,
I didn't get that fucking cake.
Oh,
you don't let me have that cake.
I can't get any cake.
I'm going to pull your fucking Dick off on a bite your nose off like that.
That is a,
as a strange trait for an animal to have.
Oh yeah.
No,
I mean,
I think it's a terrible trait for a human being to have.
Oh yeah,
we are animals.
Yeah.
It's something a you got to work on,
but when it comes to divorce,
like that's that same thing.
It's like that same,
I'm on it.
I'll fucking suffer.
I want to play your tech off.
And that's why people hire hitman and shit to kill their ex wives and kill her
ex husband's Liam.
People don't get less crazy as they age.
No,
no,
no.
A lot of times they get more because they realize it's almost over the ride's
over and now you know,
you're 65 year old lady.
No one's a fuck you and your 65 year old man,
no wants to fuck you either.
And now all of a sudden you guys are battling,
you know?
Yeah.
Battling over finances and this and that.
[inaudible].